well now you learn what i think is is is
quite possibly one of the most useful
concepts in life and then you might
already be familiar with it but if
you're not
this will will hopefully keep you from
one day
uh filing for bankruptcy so anyway i
will talk about interest and and then
simple versus compound interest so
what's interest interest we all have
heard of it interest rates or interest
on your mortgage or um you know how much
interest do i owe on my credit card so
interest
i don't know what the actual formal
definition maybe i should look it up on
wikipedia but it's essentially rent on
money so it's money that you pay in
order to keep money for some period of
time that's probably not the most
obvious definition but let me put it
this way
let's say that
i want to borrow 100
from you
so this is now
and let's say that this is one year from
now
one year and this is you
and this is me
so now you give me one hundred dollars
and then i have the hundred dollars and
a year goes by and i have a hundred
dollars here
and if i were to just give you that
hundred dollars back
you would have collected no rent you
would have just got your money back you
would have collected no interest but if
you said sal i'm willing to give you a
hundred dollars now if you give me i
don't know if you give me a hundred and
ten dollars
a year later so in this situation
how much did i pay you to keep that
hundred dollars for a year
well i'm paying you ten dollars more
right i'm returning the hundred dollars
i'm returning the hundred dollars and
i'm returning another ten dollars and so
this ten dollars this extra ten dollars
that i'm returning to you
is essentially
the fee that i paid to be able to keep
that money and do whatever i wanted with
that money and maybe save it maybe
invested do whatever
for a year and that ten dollars is
essentially the interest and a way that
is often calculated is a percentage of
the original amount that i borrowed and
the original amount that i borrowed in
fancy banker or finance terminology is
just called principle
principle
so in this case the rent on the money or
the interest was ten dollars and if i
wanted to ex do it as a percentage i
would say 10 over the principal right
which over 100
which is equal to 10
so you might have said hey sal i'm
willing to pay i'm willing to lend you a
dollar a hundred dollars if you pay me
10 interest on it so uh 10 of 100 was 10
so after a year i pay you 100 plus the
and likewise so for any amount of money
say you will you're willing to borrow
let me any amount of money for a 10
interest well then if you were to lend
me a thousand dollars
then the interest would be 10 of that
which would be 100 so then after a year
i would owe you
a thousand
plus
ten percent
ten percent times a thousand
and that's equal to eleven hundred
dollars right i just added a zero to
everything
right in this case a hundred dollars
would be the interest but it would still
be ten percent
so let me let me now make a distinction
between simple interest and compound
interest
so we we just did a fairly simple
example where you lent money for me for
a year at 10
right so let's say that someone
were to say that my interest rate
interest rate that they charge or the
interest rate they charge other people
is
well 10 is a good number 10 percent
per year
and let's say i'm going to borrow i'm
going to borrow
the principle that i'm going to borrow
from this person
the principal i'm going to borrow is a
hundred dollars
so my question to you and maybe you want
to pause it after after i pose it
is how much
how much do i owe
do i owe
in
10 years
how much do i owe in 10 years
so there's really two ways of thinking
about it you could say okay
i started see in in years at time zero
like if i just borrow the money i just
paid it back immediately i would just
pay you know it would be a hundred
dollars right i'm not going to do that
i'm going to keep it for at least a year
so after a year
just based on the example that we just
did i could add 10 percent of
that
amount
to the hundred dollars
and
it would then i would then owe a hundred
and ten dollars
and then after two years
i could add another ten percent of the
original principle right so every year
i'm just adding ten dollars so in this
case it would be 120
and in year three i would owe 130
essentially my rent per year to borrow
this hundred dollars is ten dollars
right because i'm always taking 10
percent of the original amount and after
after 10 years
because i was each year i would have had
to pay an extra 10 in interest after 10
years i would owe 200
right and that 200
is equal to 100
of principal
principal
plus 100 of interest because i paid 10 a
year of interest
and this notion of what i just did here
this is actually called simple
uh
simple interest which is essentially you
take the original amount you borrowed
the interest rate
the amount the the fee that you pay
every year is the interest rate times
that original amount and you just
incrementally pay that every year but if
you think about it you're actually
paying a smaller and smaller percentage
of what you owe going into that year and
maybe when i show you compound interest
that'll make sense so this is one way to
interpret 10 interest a year
another way to interpret it is okay so
in year zero right you still you know
it's a hundred dollars that you're
borrowing or if you just if so they
handed the money and said no no i i
don't want it and you just paid back you
know 100
after a year
you would essentially pay the hundred
dollars plus ten percent of a hundred
dollars
right which is a hundred and ten dollars
so that's one hundred
plus
ten percent
of a hundred let me switch colors
because it's monotonous
right but i think this makes sense to
you
and this is where simple and compound
interest starts to diverge in the last
situation we just kept adding ten
percent of the original hundred dollars
in compound interest in compound
interest now we don't take 10 of the
original amount we now take 10 of this
amount
right and so what are we doing every
every so
now we're going to take the original
we're going to take 110
is going to be our new you can almost
view it as our new principal it's like
we this is how much we after a year and
then we would re-borrow it right so now
we're going to 110 plus
times 110
right and that is equal to
you could actually undistribute the 110
out and that equals that's equal to
times
110. you can you can actually
um
actually 110 times 1.1
right
and so that equals
and actually i could rewrite it this way
is too i could rewrite as 100 times 1.1
squared
and that equals what's 121 dollars
and then in year two this is my new
principle this is 121. this is my new
principle and now i have to in year
three so this is year two i'm taking
more space so this is year two
and now in year three
i'm going to have to pay
the 121 dollars that i owed at the end
of
year two
plus
10 percent
times the amount of money i owed going
into the year
121 dollars
and if we and so that's the same thing
we could put parentheses around here so
that's the same thing as
1 times 121 plus 0.1 times 121 so that's
the same thing as
1.1 times 121
or another way of viewing it that's
equal to our original principle times
1.1
to the third power
and if you keep doing this and i
encourage you to do it because it'll
really give you a hands-on sense at the
end of 10 years we will owe or you i
forgot who's borrowing from whom
a hundred dollars times 1.1
to the 10th power
and what does that equal let me get my
spreadsheet out
let me just pick a random cell
so plus 100
times
point one
to the tenth power
so two hundred and fifty nine dollars
and some change
two hundred and fifty nine dollars
so it might seem like a very subtle
distinction but it ends up being a very
big difference when i compounded it 10
percent for 10 years
for 10 years using compound interest i
owe 259 dollars when i did it using
simple interest i only owed
200 so that 59 was kind of the increment
of how much more
compound interest cost me
i'm about to run out of time so i'll do
a couple more examples in the next video
just so you really get a deep
understanding of how do you compound
interest how the exponents work and and
and what really is the difference i'll
see in the next video